trying to pull it together really really
hard but it's not working okay what's
going on everybody from first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings today we're joined
by Vanessa Hudgens no guests you know
what nobody has ever said that what
until last week and then and
back-to-back weeks
somebody has suggested that so maybe I
should flip tagline well you gotta know
you gotta know the person I feel like
you gotta yeah right a little bit
overstepping you know you know from her
many hit films TV shows and even the
Broadway stage this holiday season you
can catch her starring alongside
Jennifer Lopez and second act which is
set to theatres December 21st Vanessa
Hudgens welcome to the show thank you I
know that flaming hot cheetos used to be
a part of your everyday diet so I take
it you're comfortable around spicy food
yeah I'm into it I put so much on
everything like a lot of sriracha I go
through those bottles click
[Music]
it will start up a handle what do you
mean at the handle let's see how it has
a little handle over there like this see
this okay we throw a lot at you here on
how ones not even spicy yummy enjoy that
while you can okay so second act real
tearjerker of a rom-com if I've ever
seen one in a throwback of sorts those
iconic Jennifer Lopez titles of the 90s
and like you JLo is a multi -
entertainer whose career touches music
it touches film and touches fashion did
you learn anything observing from afar
receive a piece of takeaway advice I
think just how hard she works um I think
it from the outside there was something
in my team never good from the outside
you get to see like the final product of
her hard labors but what you don't
realize is how she's like in the
trenches like she is down there and I
get her hands dirty and like fully
involved with everything and that's why
she's had the career that she has
because girl works so hard and she's so
focused and I just really admire her for
that and you know there are a lot of
films that end up in these decade-long
debates on whether or not they're
Christmas movies and I can already tell
that this one is gonna fall in with frem
lens and diehards let's get out in front
of it is it a Christmas movie I mean
part of it does take place during
Christmas so I guess that qualifies yeah
like what are the non-negotiables I know
I don't know I mean there's a Christmas
tree in it what it doesn't like really
heartfelt it's warm and fuzzy it's like
heartwarming I feel like that falls into
Christmas category but it's it's a lot
more than just that you know it deals
with like second chance
and female empowerment and like getting
in the way of yourself so some more in
common with gremlins than you might
think all right all right Vanessa you
ready to move on yeah watch you know why
oh why
i'il you like sriracha right this is
kind of like an elegant sriracha it is I
want to take it home with me well we'll
put it in your back we'll put it in your
bag you can kiss your not ones so know
that you're an adventure at heart which
for you I know means crossing things off
the bucket list and traveling the world
in between projects when did you fear
more for your life swimming with sharks
are rappelling out of a helicopter with
Bear Grylls mm-hmm I felt like I was in
a cage with sharks so I was like I'm
fine nothing's gonna happen and this is
so cool because there's a shark staring
at me swimming right towards me and
they're so weird they like stare at you
and then at the last minute turn it's
like they're playing a staring contest
but rappelling out of a helicopter I was
like this is crazy but I'm with Bear
Grylls so I know I'm gonna be okay what
oh my god yes second flosser - oh yeah
just keep that keep that gonna keep on
your bike this is gonna keep happening
this is butterfly Baker smoked onions
mmm
people would I have to smell them all
[Music]
they're all great so far we're chillin
that's good so I have nine good
authority that you're one of the best
party planners in Hollywood I know that
you keep the fog machine and storage and
stretch Halloween into month-long
celebrations can you break down the
mechanics of coming up with a theme and
then blowing it all out because there do
seem pretty elaborate they are extremely
elaborate um
oh it's starting to bite a little trying
to get that she um the theme just kind
of comes to me it's like whatever I'm
into that year whatever I'm most
inspired by this year I did not get to
have my party because there was a lot
going a lot going on um but I was like
it's going to be what what did I call it
creatures of the dark forest that's what
I wanted it to be and I was gonna set it
up so that I'm getting itchy I don't
know like I want them to feel
transported do you believe in ghosts
have you had any sort of paranormal
encounter in your life I believe in
ghosts I feel like there are there's a
spiritual warfare going on around us at
all times for short I don't know if
they're ghosts I don't know if they're
demons I don't know if there's a beer I
don't I don't know what that is but I
definitely believe there's so much going
on around us at all times that we don't
see I know that you typically watch
through your fingers but what do you
think is the goat scary movie
what greatest of all time scary movie
the ring really messed me up where the
grudge the grudge really messed me up
too yeah even when I watch movies in a
dark Theater right now he's wait for
that chick to come out like no or like
the the like backwards down the stairs
thing alright like that mess me up
no thank you all right Vanessa so you're
ready to move on yeah
[Music]
mmm-hmm
we're gonna spicy already I don't know
if I'm gonna make it I get really itchy
yeah careful careful oh you get really
hot and flustered so second act takes
place in the professional world and
there's that scene where J Lo's maxing
out the card at the department store and
now you have these companies like mmm
Lafleur and theory that are changing the
landscape of women's professional attire
so do you think that in this day and age
maybe there's more fun to be had on
screen with professional women's work
wear Oh 100%
I actually oh my gosh really itchy oh
wait
side note I'm do any of these have a lot
of black pepper what do you have allergy
or something kind of yeah I guess you
know I'll take a look at all the labels
going forward I get hives Oh shown for
you yeah yeah I didn't think about that
until just now wait am i itching fit I
love the feeling that I have when I put
on a suit it's like armor you know there
was a time where they said that the that
the pantsuit that it was dead but it's
had a renaissance as of late you poured
gasoline on that fire with the SU Studio
Collection so with that in mind I want
to bounce some iconic pantsuit fits all
of you and I'm just curious what you
think is a Power Suit maven and we will
start with Bianca Jagger she used to do
the double breasted thing yep she was
the inspiration this actual suit was the
inspiration for one of my suits she it's
like my style icon and I feel like no
one did the perfect balance of
masculinity meets feminie um the way
that Bianca Jagger did is there such a
thing as too much power shoulder here's
Lady Gaga and Marc Jacobs look looking
like little pump in the I love you
oh my god I love that song I was there
this the night that she wore this suit
and her whole thing was like she tried
on all these dresses and she listed all
the designers that they were but she put
this suit on and she felt like herself
and I feel like that's something that we
all deserve to be able to leave a house
and approach the world feeling truly
empowered in who we are as individuals
so for her this is perfect
Diane Keaton at the 2014 Academy Awards
classic or pass
I mean classic for Diane Keaton she's
another one like Annie Hall it's just
she embraces the masculine meets
feminine like there's a lot going on
here I don't know I would wear it but
like she does it and she does it well
just do a Lipa the new queen of this
pantsuit look she rocks this all the
time she looks incredible she forgot to
top though thoughts on the Madonna
number from the Grammys and 2014 iconic
this is just perfection there's a dual
glove with a cane like full pimp mama
status I proved this message
bang-bang all right are you ready to
move on no I don't know is throw a lot
of I pepper in this I would shake how
can we tell I'm like serious oh god I'm
scared
[Music]
if last one was hotter it's out goes
sometimes would be careful about being
old and got false sense of security you
know be careful you're going there
you're going no this one's fine
the habanero mango messed me up way more
than los Caliente it's more like not so
Cali anything whoa
shots fired all right Vanessa we have a
record segment on our show called
explaining that Graham we do a deep dive
on our guest Instagram post interesting
pictures that need more context so bust
out the laptop I'll show you the picture
you just saw it's the bigger story does
that sound okay all right laptop please
how you doing so far Club is really
delicious
all right sip and rose' with the hippos
I know I felt like I should not be doing
that but they told me that it would be
okay
I had always thought that like hippos
were one of the most dangerous creatures
that's what they say you know they have
like The Hungry Hungry Hippos everybody
thinks hippos they're so fun they danced
in Fantasia but in real life they're
just savage I thought the day you were
savage I was like are you sure we can
get out here and do this but they're
like yeah totally cool it smell horrible
naturally what was your favorite
takeaway from the Safari in the
Serengeti are they all they're cracked
up to be
um yeah it is epic I really wanted to
catch Lions mating I don't know why I'm
sharing that I did though like I thought
it would be so exciting and we found
these two lions who apparently were
going to get at it and they didn't and
then we left
um but that's how cheetah that had just
eaten something so there was blood all
over it which was iconic um it's just
magical but it's really funny because
after being there for a while you're
like enough zebras give me something
exciting I have one more for you do you
have a favorite gucci mane memory from
your time on the spring breakers that i
love
he is just like the biggest teddy bear I
don't think it wasn't written but like
they shoot some rounds off and then he
goes like that is classic gucci mane so
I'd always be like but I love him he's
crushing it too
[Music]
hmm that's great you like this one
I love curries I didn't get you in the
back of my throat uh-huh
oh good so every Hollywood star has a
story or two about bizarre face-to-face
interactions with fans but if you ever
endure the kind of Beatlemania frenzy
that you experience as a Disney Channel
star which was tougher to deal with the
screaming between fan are the screaming
tween fans mom uh I think the moms
that's what people say yeah because it's
like they'll do anything for their
children it's like I remember running to
my plane because we were on a press tour
and we were like running really late and
we were flying commercially running to
the gate and this mom sees me and she
starts like fall like chasing me almost
she's like wait Lana there's your permit
her and I was like honestly I'm about to
miss my plane I gotta go she's like come
on you owe me this I was like what and
she's like I need a picture for my
daughters like I have to code she's like
you're a [ __ ]
literally minding my own business and
getting harassed by women is there
anything that's funny about the dads hmm
I mean like they're so sweet they're
always so sweet I have such an affinity
towards dads it's like they're just like
bashful and like I kind of like I don't
want to like embarrass anyone but like
the thing is it's like it's it's a more
calm
timid approach which is just so charming
to me
are you ready to move on to the
firewater yeah
fiery I'm gonna let that one be mm-hmm
okay
so it's inevitable for someone as famous
as you to get involved in a controversy
or kerfuffle from time to time and I'm
not interested a kerfuffle it's a great
word I'm not interested in any of the
details or bringing anything up but I am
curious about your take on the anatomy
of a Hollywood scandal do you feel like
it's getting harder to escape flare-ups
but easier to shake them off Kirk a
great question um yes because there is
so much nowadays that people are
ingesting in the day and age of social
media and Instagram
we are constantly being diluted with so
much from different people different
things it's like a constant influx of
information that we're taking in all the
time so when things happen they're here
but then something else happens and then
that's gone so yeah I feel like it is
moving a lot more rapidly this next one
is de bomb are you ready to move on from
just boom oh I was thinking Doug bears
[Music]
yeah Wow yeah it like kinda gives me a
headache just smelling it a small baby
[Music]
I liked it does it count I have to bite
it oh my god my ears are itching
oh I did it yeah it's uh it's going down
what a way to close out the junket oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh Unleashed as
someone who's been dubbed the queen of
Coachella an event mainstay since 2010
what's one thing the haters get right
when they complain about the downfall of
festival culture too many people there's
way too many people really aggressive
besides drink plenty of water and bring
sunblock is there a hack that you can
share with the people out there for
surviving festival weekend
many fans many fans are a great bonus
also for women powder compacts
Ming SHINee is not a cute little thing
oh my god I'm dying
Coachella has become the get of fit off
Instagram festival of record and now
know that you're very gracious you're
very complimentary but can you give the
people
but if you had to bury one Coachella
style trend what would it be
um most people would say flower crowns
but the flower crowns I'm magical like
I'll wear a flower count Contador
Renaissance Festival
so it's a great festival thing I'm
trying to pull it together really really
hard but it's not working
it's okay just let it go just let it go
I'm scared
this next one is the XRS ko with Medusa
on the bottle yeah okay
Jesus Christ it was so intense that one
yeah okay
Oh God my mouth is still on fire I say
it a lot but you remember early on when
you were like these are easy these are
fun
yeah that really hurts right nap Tony
wait I'm sweating I feel like I can't
even smell anymore sure I was gonna say
it tasted sweet but now it hurts all
right Vanessa your career it's touched
so many different projects from tweens
to blockbusters to TV shows and music
videos and your co-stars are equally
running the gamut and I think that the
lead for that would be David Bowie's
cameo in your film Bandslam ray popped
up and somebody liked your pop punk band
I know that was pretty iconic I loved
David Bowie and it was the last movie
that he's been in I feel like I'm having
a really hard time talking right now
Elaine Goldsmith Thomas who is actually
Jennifer's producing partner did produce
that movie Bandslam as well so throwback
what was it like seeing James Franco
method act on the set of spring breakers
it was insane I remember before he got
there we were just filming basically a
bunch of like almost naked girls like
making out with each other and I was
like what kind of movie are we making
and then he got there and I was like oh
okay I mean I'd say 80% of what he did
was improved like the script was a tiny
little script and he brought so much to
the character he was just insane it was
so much fun to be able to work with him
like that does anything in your acting
career prepare you to shoot an episode
of drunk history
[Music]
hmm no I don't know I mean like I love
those guys so much I always have so much
fun with them I've done three now and
whenever they call I'm like I'll be
there whenever you need me it's just so
much fun they're crazy and like they're
just having a great time they're like
big kids having fun what do you remember
about 50 cent playing your pimp and
frozen ground now it'd be like he's my
[ __ ] bimp mm-hmm I gets to say
that like he was actually my pimp
CIMB he was my PA MP he was so sweet
though
are you doing that or don't they already
have them on them they do but this is
the last dab and we call it the last dab
because it's tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing you
don't have to if you don't want to
Vanessa Hudgens I will put a DAB on my
board and then dip it there you go
veteran move is on fire this is really
painful huh yeah shake okay
hey dabbed the depth the dab
[Music]
I'm the bite
okay Vanessa Hudgins here we are at the
end of our ten wing run and we've talked
a lot about what makes Vanessa Hudgens
tick but one thing we haven't touched on
is your stage career whether it's grease
live rgg on Broadway and as I understand
it one of the ways that you'd prepare
for these shows is by doing tongue
twisters backstage so now that we've
eaten some of the hottest vegan chicken
wings in the history of planet Earth
mouths of flame tongues on fire
can you teach me some of your go twos in
Topeka over and over again as fast as
you can
- pika - pika - pika - pika - pika pika
- pika - pika - pika pika - pika pika
pika - because you'll be good to be here
relevant irrelevant irrelevant
irrelevant yellow red leather yellow
leather what rub go red leather yellow
leather red leather yellow leather red
leather yellow red leather yellow
leather red leather yellow leather red
leather yellow but I gotta get a butter
butter get it gonna put up on I get it
get a butter but I get it get about it
but it got it in a butter but I got it
kind of - but I got a good a butter but
I got a got a butter got a but I've got
a gun about it but I got a gun a footer
but I got a gonna butter but I've got a
gonna but I'm gonna gonna but I'm gonna
get well thank you so much for the
lesson vanessa hudgens and look at you
you Queen at the end of the junk ten
chicken wings up ten chicken wings down
choking out every hot sauce we have on
the board and now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you Vanessa audience this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life Oh
I better like thanks bye um go see
second act out in theaters December 21st
what rent live on box January 27th and
make sure you check out my movie on
Netflix princess which it's great
crystals movie as well as Poehler which
is another movie on Netflix that'll be
out January 25th check it out I feel
like I'm cold I don't know why my body
is like reacting like I'm freezing hey
what's going on spice Lords this is Sean
Evans checking in by his lonesome and
you know what that means
it's time for another hot sauce PSA and
for two years we've been working on
making the perfect entry level sauce
something that's good for everyone
number one on our board and now it is
finally here the classic is our
contemporary twist on the original
vinegar-based sauces throughout American
history with chili de arbol peppers and
garlic for that perfect balance as
always people who order the hot ones
monthly subscription box got it first
but now it's available for everyone heat
nice calm heat nice calm to pick up the
classic the classic
it's for the people
[Music]